look now it's called lazy writing
[Music]
okay so here the white Walker just grabs Johnstone
shoulder for no reason and you could have
just stab them in the back
after disarming Jon Snow though white Walker
could have easily killed him with the pointy
end of the sword but doesn't and just hits
him off
[Applause]
[Applause] [Music] [Applause]
how convenient five minutes later
sweet
[Music]
she's okay she strapped down half a river
and walked through half the city to find lady
crane but he cares about blood loss get killed
walk it off no no I cannot when I see one
sweet guy
are you sure about that
[Music]
he also survives the cavalry charge by just
standing still amazing
[Applause]
they're shooting so many arrows
[Music]
[Applause] [Music]
easy clap
ten abroad must have the fastest reaction
time Jesus
weighed the torment does take a sword to the
face shouldn't that like split open his head
or a never mind he drinks shines bone he's
okay and he's getting ganked by like five
whites they have weapons why are they hugging
one eyelid bleed in
[Music]
it's pretty sad that uncle Benjen is just
used as a deus ex machina figure and gives
people get out of jail free cards
no do it say the word
basically like every character on the battlefield
has an instance where they should have died
here
this moment is also pretty insulting Aria
is basically dead to rights and then the zombies
get stuck in the door are you kidding me
this scene is infuriating because up until
this point the whites were just running around
in attacking people now they're just walking
at Jon Snow when they outnumber him quiet
by the way she fell off her dragon like 30
seconds ago and Jorah was behind the gates
in Winterfell
all right this clip takes place a few minutes
later boats actually analyze what's happened
in here we can see Jamie clearly good dogpile
by like four whites and then bran in the background
just getting hugged by his zombie eldest Lee
Podrick out of this since his rod can defeat
anyone [Music]
[Music]
seize him cut his throat stop oh wait I've
changed my mind let him go
and very dead so a new king has chosen to
send you to the Nights Watch no execution
for killing Daenerys Targaryen easiest clap
of the century